[Music]
Alabama lawmakers could send a bill to
the governor this week that would let a
megachurch establish its own police
force the bill would grant Briarwood
Presbyterian Church the ability to hire
officers with the same powers as
traditional cops there's already passed
the state Senate is now waiting a house
vote
David Beck knows in Birmingham where the
plan is getting mixed reactions David
good morning good morning Gail we're
used to hearing the church talk about
God's law but in this case the church is
asking for its very own man-made law now
Briarwood is more than just a church
it's got a daycare a seminary and a
school which is spread across two
different campuses that are actually
nine miles apart and it's the concern
for the kids safety that's the main
reason this church says we need our own
police force
[Music]
Briarwood Presbyterian Church sits on
the buckle of the Bible Belt beyond
Sunday services the church claims as
many as eight thousand people pass
through its campuses daily concerned
about safety Briarwood is asking the
state legislature to allow it to hire
its own cops with all the powers of law
enforcement officers religion reporter
Greg garrison has covered this for
al.com
why can't the church just hire off-duty
officers or sheriff's deputies in the
area that's what they already do but
they say sometimes they have difficulty
getting enough to staff all their events
why can't they just rely on 911 for help
if they need it well they could but they
believe that to be truly secure at all
their events they need security
officials there a shooting this past
weekend injured five teenagers and a
baby at another church just 15 miles
north of here in a statement Briarwood
pointed to recent mass shootings at
churches and schools to reinforce their
need saying the sole purpose of this
proposed legislation is to provide a
safe environment for the church its
members students and guests Randall
Marshall is with the ACLU of Alabama the
church is worried about what if what if
something happens why why is it a
problem to have a police force it's a
problem because it violates the First
Amendment to the US Constitution this
takes what is a core governmental power
the police power invested in the hands
of a religious organization as a church
Briarwood would not be the first church
with its own police force the Washington
National Cathedral has 18 police
officers many observers expect Alabama's
lawmakers will give their blessing on
the Briarwood law the conservative
Christian churches have a lot of power
in Alabama politics
and if for our would Presbyterian Church
says we need a police department I think
a lot of people say sure they need a
police department without asking a ton
of question without asking a ton of
questions five times over four days we
tried to get an interview with the
church but they did not want to talk on
camera the ACLU is prepared to sue if
this becomes law now Norah it's worth
noting last year this same bill sailed
through the Alabama Legislature but it
died on the governor's desk because he
didn't sign it
now there's a new governor and she's
taking a look at whether or not it's a
good idea for her to sign it right David
it's a really interesting story too I
like how he phrased that right on the
buckle of the Bible Belt yeah great
story David thank you